boundary changes are being presented for
Clark County schools and some of these
could impact your children yeah major
proposals we're talking about for
changes in the growing Northwest and
Southeast Valley Joshua peguero was at
today's meeting with why certain schools
are being impacted
these changes are meant to ease the
overcrowding of high schools and with
several homes being developed in these
areas there's a concern that until more
schools are built things will get worse
Arbor View is packed there's 24
Portables there's no space available for
the kids to eat at lunch my son goes to
the school there so I'm very well aware
of the pack classroom sizes and there's
no space available for the for the
school to grow on its own
sits on the attendance Zone advisory
commission that covers the Northwest
Valley the group voted in favor of a
proposal that moves about 200 students
from Arbor View High School to
Centennial it also sends 20 students
from Indian Springs to Centennial as you
can see on the map centennial's boundary
has been expanded that area is booming
right now that it's not just built and
purchased permits they are putting
houses down Alex mcgurk has a son at
Arbor View High School she thinks the
zoning commission is ignoring families
in the far Northwest have more future
Development coming and we do not have a
school will propose until 2028 that
means we have to go six more years it
with only two high schools money has
been set aside for a new high school to
be built in the Northwest Valley there
are currently 728 12th graders at Arbor
View and 625 a centennial another High
School boundary change focuses on
Henderson sending 277 Coronado students
to Green Valley High School Green
Valley's boundary is extending South to
the 215 between Green Valley Parkway and
Stephanie this is to provide an
enrollment relief for Coronado Anna
binder represents this district and
right now you know people complain a lot
about our schools being overcrowded but
our most overcrowded schools are our
high schools these new boundary changes
still have to be adopted by the Clark
County School District trustees that
meeting is scheduled for next Thursday
Joshua progero 8 News Now